I I Journal so I Journal all the time
and so I could actually go to the day
and time that I was feeling certain ways
and you could read through the writing
that I have of like what I went through
and when my heart started changing and I
said a prayer and I said God like I
truly feel like I'm not in the place
that I should be so even if it breaks me
or hurts me take my feet and plant them
where they need to be and through that
very wild storm
I wouldn't change a second of it and let
me tell you Howie I'm not trying to be
dramatic
bro there was times I passed out fell
down the stairs because of just I was so
scared what was your what was your
biggest fear like what would you be
scared of my biggest fear is that I
worked this hard
to leave and
people made me out to be a man I'm not
and that I had to exit being a man I
wasn't proud of because of editing or
certain ways they try to paint me and so
I thought if I left that I'd be hated
and there have been so many YouTube
people like big YouTubers that made
videos taking out even them not only did
my team do that for me but like these
guys would only highlight what I did
wrong and it broke me but go read the
comments you can't hide the truth even
Their audience were like absolutely not
and it like for example there was a guy
named sunnyv2 he made a video about me
like literally three days ago has like
three million views why I ruined the
biggest show 99 of the comments were
like you got this wrong this is and
they're explaining it in paragraphs so I
moved and the people moved with me and
on impulsive we discussed Mike Logan and
me they said I asked the question I go
would you rather have the belt and the
whole world think you lost or lose and
have the whole world know you win and
they said they were to have the Bell and
I said I'd rather have the world and
that's how it worked were you scared to
walk away because of what you thought
others would think of you how they would
perceive you are you that can are you
concerned about
the perception of who you are I am
because I hold a responsibility of
setting an example of a man I am and I
try to portray that so men could be a
good good human being while working hard
and accomplishing things that they
probably couldn't unless they cheated or
they did something wrong and so what I
took this long road by my bring my
manager in here he's brought me a
million dollar offers for gambling and I
said I want to [__] do it for a
billion dollars and I've turned down way
more money and nobody will ever know the
decisions that I made behind closed
doors and then they started editing and
started doing things and and it just I
don't care about money I don't care
about Fame to a certain extent I care
about being the best human being that I
could possibly be in achieving the
highest level that I can so if you're
gonna steal something from me take my
money take take my pride take my ego but
don't don't take away what I took and my
parents took to build who I am because
there is a young version of me that's
following in my steps and what happens
if he sees a light that I wasn't
portrayed to be in and now he walks away
from a foundation that I'm very much
believe in
I guess the big question is
um
is there any way your manager can get me
those gambling uh I'm getting you a
Celsius I already made a Celsius call
yeah but you just said it's a million
dollar gambling brand if she's listening
I'm I'm available are you even listening
I don't give a [__] okay but what so
what is the biggest on a serious note
what is the biggest
um misconception of you and what
happened there that you
that bothered you
and it's not true and maybe they got
that misconception because of the way
you were editorialized or
I'm really not they they very much made
it clear that I'm not allowed to speak
up about things
so I I can't even legally yeah
did was this a I didn't know that you
guys were in a legal well
he likes to tend to argue with me and so
he argues with me on the podcast and
about things and uh I think he
I said okay then how about we discuss
this what you've guys done let's talk
about this and he goes yeah do it and
then I go okay and so I tweet it out uh
I wasn't going to talk out of respect
out of respect for the man so and then
his attorneys hit me up and said hey let
me remind you about the stuff you've
signed and I said oh so not that and I
don't know if if this could be I I
wanted to be respectful of everybody
yeah you know and uh Logan
um you know he does his podcast here
when he's here and uh I don't know him
that well and he works with uh Proto and
things like that and I said I just said
because I didn't want to cross the line
and I don't want to cross the line with
you yeah but so I uh I asked him if I
could you could have me on he probably
said yeah because you know I wouldn't I
would not ask if he can have you on I
can have anybody on but what I said to
him because I'll show you what I said to
him because I'm going to show I'm going
to share this with you do you know how
to get to your messages
get me to my messages yeah here's what I
said to him I said I'm having George on
you know and if there's some place that
you don't want me to tread because
either of you would get in trouble uh
you know
legally or whatever and he answered I'm
just trying to look for his thing
he said I can talk about anything yeah
knowing that you can't yes exactly oh
okay
and also it's like I I don't know I
don't want to do that that's not how my
parents raised me to be I don't know
okay he just said I can talk about
anything I that that's all he said I
could talk you could talk about anything
I said I don't want to step on if this
is legal if this is and I don't want to
I don't want to offend you but you're
here to defend your you don't have to
defend yourself I'm a fan and of
everything you do and I'm a fan of
Logan's you know I did the podcast and I
had a great time on it
he hasn't come on mine but and you have
[Music]